تفاصيل التحقيق مع اشرف حكيمي بتهمه
الاغتصاب وتفاعل واسع مع تحقيق حلم طفلين
بلقاء رونالدو و25 سؤال مع نجم مسامير
طراد ريتشارد كلب الاسد اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
مازال اسم اللاعب المغربي اشرف حكيمي لاعب
منتخب المغرب ونادي باريس سان جيرمان
عنوان رئيسي في الاخبار والناس بتتابع
بترقب تطورات اتهام فتالوبي الاغتصاب
البنت قالت انه في يناير بداوا يتكلموا
على انستجرام وفي 25 فبراير اتفقوا يلتقوا
وبعتلها لبيته وهناك اغتصبها وعرفت تدفه
في الاخر وتهرب وتطلب صحبتها بمسج انه
تيجي تاخذهم والبنت للتذكير قالت للشرطه
انها بتثبت حالها بس وانما تبغى ترفع دعوه
او تشتكي لكن السلطات قررت انها تحقق في
الموضوع لشهره حكيمي ولخطوره القصه
فاستجوبوا البنت والخميس استجوب حكيمي
كمان اللي نفذتهما من اول يوم وبعد
التحقيق والاستجواب النيابه وجهت رسميا
لحكيمي تهمه الاغتصاب ووضع تحت المراقبه
والاشراف القضائي ومنعوه انه يتواصل مع
الفتاه ويتكلم معاها لكن في نفس الوقت
قالت انه مسموح له يغادر الاراضي الفرنسيه
محاميه حكيمي صرحت للاعلام بعد توجيه
التهم وقالت انه موكلها ضحيه لمحاوله
ابتزاز من قبل الفتاه اللي مو متعاونه مع
العداله وانها مرضت تعمل فحوص نفسيه وطبيه
ولكن محاميه الفتاه قالت انه كلها بالكلام
مو مهم وانه موكلتها لسه مو جاهزه انها
تواجه حكيمي الشخص الثاني اللي بياكد
براءه حكيمي هي والدته اللي اشتهرت بشكل
كبير في مونديال قطر وشفناهم مع بعض في
اغلب الصور والاحتفالات السيده سعيده قالت
انه قلبها بيقول لها انه ابنها بريء وقالت
انها سالته واقسم لها ببراءته وقالت انه
الناس كلها بتشهد باخلاقه وتساءلت كيف
ممكن يعمل كده في غياب مرته والبيت فيه
حراس وكاميرات مراقبه تصريحات والده حكيمي
جاءت الرغم تاكيدها ان محاميته طلبت من كل
افراد العائله عدم الادلاء بتصري للاعلام
في الوقت الراهن حكيمي للان متهم فقط لا
تمت ادانته ولا شيء ومثل ما كلنا نعرف
المتهم بريء حتى تثبت ادانته لكن رغم هذا
الشيء في معسكرات كبيره اونلاين حاسمه
الموضوع وجالسه بتتخانق عليه في شريحه
خلاص ادانت حكيمي وبتنتقدوا اشد الانتقاد
وبالدين وبتستنكر وشريحه ثانيه لا بتدافع
باستماته عنه وبتسخر من البنت اللي مشتكيه
وروايتها وبتجزم انه حكيمي ضحيه ابتزاز
طيب احنا معانا من باريس مراسل العربيه
فادي الدهوك والمتابع للقضيه من اول يوم
اهلا فيك معانا فادي هل عندك المزيد من
التفاصيل عن التحقيقات اللي جرت مع اطراف
القضيه
اهلا ساره الجديد في هذه القضيه هو ان
القضاء الان منكب على فحص عدد من
المداولات جرت بين ثلاثه اطراف بين اشرف
حكيمي من جهه والشاب التي تتهمه وبين
الشاب التي تتهمه واحدى صديقاتها في هذه
المحادثات ما يخص اشرف حكيمي وهذه الفتاه
قام اشرف حكيمي بحسب المعلومات التي
نشرتها عدد من الصحف الفرنسيه من مصادر
مقربه من التحقيق قام بتسليم كل هذه
المحادثات الى القضاء ليطلع عليها لكن
المفاجاه ان الشاب التي تتهمه لم تقم
بتسليم المحادثات من جانبها وقالت انها
قامت بحذف حساب انستقرام التي الذي كانت
تتحدث معه
عبره مع حكيمي من جهه ثانيه المحادثات
بينها وبين صديقتها هي قالت في الشهاده
التي قدمتها لمركز الشرطه عندما
ذهبت اليه في اليوم التالي من الواقعه
قالت انها وصلت الى هناك قرابه الساعه
الواحده بعد منتصف الليل اشرف حكيمي ارسل
لها سياره اجره مكثت في شقته نحو ساعه هنا
بدا
بملامستها بتقبيلها قبل ان يقوم باغتصابها
بحسب روايتها وهنا قامت بالاتصال باحدى
صديقاتها التي جاءت لكي تنقذها من هذا
الموقف بحسب ما تقول السلطات او القضاء
يحاول فهم بعض الرسائل يقولون او تم
استخدام عباره من قبل المصادر التي سربت
هذه الاخبار ان هناك لغز في هذه المبادلات
بين الشاب التي تتهم اشرف حكيمي وبين
صديقتها يحاولون فك بعض هذه الرسائل هناك
لغه غير مفهومه تم التحدث فيها ربما تكون
لغه لغه او كلام بين اصدقاء عبارات تستخدم
بشكل خاص بين اصدقاء يحاولون فهمها وهذا
هو الامر المهم والملح بالدرجه الاولى حتى
الان في هذه القضيه
يعني في وسط هذا
الغموض اللي حاصل وفي وسط الكلام انه
الفتاه رافضه الفحص الطبي ورفض الفحص
النفسي والموضوع يعني عدى عليه وقت كيف
ممكن وهي طبعا ناكد كمان ونرجع نذكر انه
البنت مو رافعه دعوه هذا حق عام كيف يمكن
اثبات التهمه اصلا على اشرف حكيمي
حتى الان كل ما يحصل في هذه القضيه هو
ادعاءات او هو اقوال هذه الشابه
ويقع المسؤوليه لاثبات هذه الادعاءات على
الطرف المدعي على محاميتها هذه المساله
اضافت تعقيدات كثيره جدا على القضيه لانها
اولا ترفض مواجهه اشرف حكيمي ترفض ايضا ان
تسلم او ان تقوم برفع شكوى رسميه ضده هو
لا يواجه شكوى بالاغتصاب وانما هناك تحقيق
او تحقيق تلقائي في قضيه من هذا النوع لكن
ايضا هي ترفض الخضوع الى فحوصات طبيه كان
يمكن ان تكشف بما لا يدعم مجالا للشك انها
تعرضت للاغتصاب لانها توجهت في اليوم
التالي فقط من هذه القضيه الى مركز الشرطه
لكنها ترفض اجراء هذه الفحوصات هذه القضيه
قد تؤثر على الاشخاص كثيرين حقيقه ليس فقط
على اشرف حكيمي على عائلته من جهه على
نادي باريس سان جيرمان حيث اقف الان هنا
امام هذا النادي وخصوصا ايضا على صديق
اشرف حكيمي نجم النادي كيليان مبابي الذي
يلازم اشرب حكيمي في كل الوقت يذهبان
اينما ذهب احدهما سوف يكون الاخر متواجد
يلتقطان الصور يقضيان معظم العطلات مع
بعضهما البعض وهذه المساله ستكون حساسه
جدا للجميع حتى ان النادي هناك اخبار تقول
ان
الفريق الفني للنادي ممتعه قليلا من سلوك
اشرف حكيمي لان النادي اختار دعم لاعبه
ليس ضد هذه السيده وليس لاثبات براءته
ولكن لانه الان هو في طور الاتهام والمتهم
بريء حتى تثبت ادانته لذلك هم يمتعضون من
سلوك اشرف حكيمي لانه يتعامل مع المساله
وكان لا شيء ضده لا يواجه هذه التهمه هو
يتصرف بشكل طبيعي
يقوم بالتقاط الصور وبالمزاح خلال
التدريبات وهذا ما اثار نوع من الغضب في
صفوف اداره النادي طيب على العموم المدرب
مدرب باريس سان جيرمان ام سئل فيه المؤتمر
الصحفي وطلب من الصحفيين عدم توجيه اي
اسئله لو عن اشرف حكيمي او ما يحدث له
حاليا او هذه القضيه تحديدا على العموم
طبعا لانه لا زال الموضوع في طور التحقيق
وحنتابع هذه القضيه اكيد بنشكرك فادي
الدهوك مراسل العربيه من باريس على هذه
المعلومات شكرا لك
ربيع شاهين طفل سوري من محافظه اللاذقيه
اسمه اخبار من اسابيع محطه اهتمام كثير من
الناس والسبب فيديو قصير عبر فيه عن حلمه
واليوم حلم ربيع تحقق للي ما سمع ايش كان
حلم ربيع خلينا نسمعه
اذا بتروح الملعب بتاخد معاك مين
ان شاء الله وان شاء الله
شو اسمك انت وين ساكن انا بمسبح الشعب
تعرفت عليك
الله يحفظك
زين ان شاء الله يا رب العالمين وخذ وياك
اللي تبغى تاخذه معاك ان شاء الله زين
وتسلم على رونالدو اوكي ويلبسك الفالينه
صح يلا الله يوفقك ان شاء الله
يتابعونا ولدنا يحب النصر السعودي هنا
نحنا في سوريا وهذا البطل يبغى يشوف
كريستيانو رونالدو ما ندري يمكن في يوم من
الايام نشوفك في الملعب
الفيديو اللي شفتوه لربيع خلال مقابله
اجريت معه اثناء تغطيه اثار الزلزال
المدمر في سوريا وبراءه ربيع وكلامه عن
حلمه بلقاء النجمه البرتغالي لاعب نادي
النصر السعودي كريستيانو رونالدو خطف قلوب
الكثيرين من الناس ومن بينهم رئيس هيئه
الترفيه المستشار تركي ال الشيخ اللي اعاد
نشر الفيديو عنوان التغريده بعباره ترحيب
بالطفل واسرته في المملكه وطلب من الناس
انه يوصلوا للطفل وفعلا ما في ايام الا
وشفنا فيديو لربيع وامه واخوانه في مطار
الرياض وبيعبروا عن سعادتهم بالتواجد في
السعوديه والحماس مليله انه راح يلتقي
اسطوره رونالدو
كان حلمي يشوف رونالدو اليوم انا احاول
كريستيانو رونالدو لانيتو بيعرف يلعب بابا
نفسي يكون العب نفسه وتدرب بالنص السعودي
[موسيقى]
النص السعودي
حبيبي طيب ومن بعد ما حقق تركي ال الشيخ
حلمي ربيع عبر بتغريزه عن فرحته بالموضوع
اما ربيع فقال انه مو مصدق انه حلمو تحقق
[موسيقى]
حلمي
تخلص هالحلم ما بعرف
ان شاء الله ما يكون حلم يا رب
طيب مو بس ربيع ففي طفل سعودي من ذوي
الاحتياجات الخاصه اسمه ابراهيم العنيزي
نشر فيديو عبر تيك توك وقال للمستشار تركي
ال الشيخ انه النصراوي وانه حلمو يحضر
للنصر مباراه ويلتقي برونالدو وفعلا بعد
ان انتشرت صوره من لقاء ابراهيم برونالدو
[موسيقى]
يا شيخ تكفى يا شيخ احضر لي مباراه وودينا
انتظرني مكسور
اعمل ايه طيب ربيع وابراهيم ماده من بعد
ما التقوا برونالدو
وشاركوا في تشجيع لاعبهم وحقيقه
الفيديوهات لوحدها بتعكس كم الفرحه
والسعاده اللي شعروا فيها
[موسيقى]
اهلا من جديد مسامير مسلسل رسوم متحركه
في 2012 على يوتيوب وحقق نجاح وساءت ترجم
على صوره عمل هو محافظه مسامير واللي بدا
حصريا على نتفليكس في يونيو 2021 ومن كم
يوم بس انطلق على المنصه ايضا الموسم
الثاني من محافظه مسامير
مساء الخير ممنوع دخول الكلاب الا
اذا
زومبي هناك انواع المتعدده من كلاب الخدمه
كلاب خدمه
ست حلقات جديده طرحت لاول مره عبر نتفليكس
في استمرار للنجاح الكبير اللي شهدوا
الموسم الاول المسلسل بيقدم سوره المشهد
المتطور في السعوديه بقالب من الكوميديا
السوداء والفكاهه ونفس الشخصيه المحبوبه
واللي اطوارها غريبه اللي حبوها الناس
وتعودوا
احتفالا بالموسم الجديد من محافظه مسامير
بالضبط
وكان لنا معه 25 سؤال مختلفه جدا من كثر
ما هو اصلا مختلف لقينا انه يستاهل انه
نعمل له استثناء نعرض المقابله الاحد بدل
من الخميس طبعا انا بتكلم عن اقتراض
كلب الاسد يعني اعتقد بدون مبالغه هذه
واحده من اكثر المقابلات اللي ضحكت فيها
في حياتي انا بنفسكم واحكموا وانا حاتركم
واعودوا القاكم غدا ان شاء الله في امان
الله
الاسد 25 سؤال لازم نجاوب عليهم بسرعه ومن
غير تفكير متى حيبدا المجتمع يحترمك بعد
ما يحترمك بخمس دقائق
بريطانيه وانت كلب هجين هذه الخلطه ميزتك
بايش والله واجد الميزات يعني
مين عدوك اللدود في محافظه مسامير
طب ليش ساكن مع الاستراحه
هل سبق وفكرت في الهجره عم افكر تقاعد في
خميس مشيط
طيب فين بتشوف نفسك بعد عشر سنين مرحوم
مرحوم
حمد ربه على العمر
طيب اوكي الله يطول عمرك ان شاء الله من
واحد لعشره لاي درجه انت ذكي
ممكن تعيدون السؤال
من واحد لعشره لاي درجه انت ذكي
سبعه اوكي طيب واخدك وقتها قررت طيب اوكي
مو مشكله هل لقيت نصفك الثاني والله يعتمد
على اداءك في المقابله
[ضحك]
خلص خلص خلص
عمرك ما لقيت نصفك الثاني طيب متى ستحصل
على البطوله المطلقه
اوكي طيب انت انت ايش برايك اهم نصيحه
للانتر بنور الناجح نصيحه للانتربول
في القصيم
كم انتقدت اجر على العمل
التخلص من الجثه هذه 25 الف زياده
اتكلم على محافظه
في الراس والجثه
طيب لو ما كنت كلب تكون قندس
اوكي هل خضعت لا تجميل
بصراحه نعم مره مو باين عليك ايش سويت
سويته ابتسامه بوليود
طيب ايش برنامجك المفضل
طبعا الدكتوره فوزيه رائعه
وعندها متابعين كثار كمان انت متهم
بالنجاسه كيف ترد والله
تتعارض مع مخالطه للبشر
مين اكثر احد تكره بعد سعد غنام
بتستعمل الفاظ خارجه كثير فين التربيه يا
طراد
والله يعني التربيه اخر نكته في المدرسه
ايش الفرق بالعالم الحيوان والانسان
او حكمه تحبه
اقعدوا عندي اثنين صراحه
الفرج ايوه
ما تحس انهم يعني شويه يعني عكس بعض يعتمد
على السياق
استغفرك واتوب اليك يا الله طب لو ما كنت
ممثل ايش كنت تحب تكون محرج تيوس
محرجه تيوس اوكي من اكثر احد بتستمتع
بمتابعته اون لاين
يعني اكيد طبعا بس في محتوى معين يعني
بيعجبك والله احب الريكوته في المسلسلات
عالميه زي نتفليكس ومسلسلك صار مدبلج للغه
خطوتك الجايه عالميا تحب تكون مع مين
والله افكر امثل
خيار يعني رائع
خيار جيد في تصور
طيب انت تحب الغناء غني لنا اغنيه تعبر عن
حياتك
فهمت عليه
هكذا
[موسيقى]